>> Hey YouTubers and the 500 million adolescent
girls that are out there in the world living
in developing countries, we had a meeting
today
that I just came out of where we had over
25 companies, and we had the
head of UN Aid, UNICEF, the UN High Commissioner
for refugees.
We had the head of some of the largest NGOs
in the world, and we all
got together and we talked about you, and
we talked about what we need
to do to change your challenges.
So obviously, the situation for adolescent
girls in the world is really
challenging.
We talked about the unique challenges that
you face, and what we need
to do and that's it time to stop talking about
it but actually really
take action.
So what we agreed to do was to count you,
first of all.
Right now, the data that's collected around
the world by all these
important organizations doesn't reflect you,
doesn't break you into an
age group that can be identified.
You're clumped into women or you're clumped
into youth.
You're not identified.
So we agreed to do that.
Then we can do the most important thing which
is invest in you because
real money needs to go to programs that are
help improve your lives.
So we talked about how we would specifically
do that and who would take
leadership roles to make that happen.
And then thirdly we talked about advocacy
and how we need to speak out
on your behalf, and give you a means to have
your voices heard so that
people can hear your stories and hear how
the life of a girl in poverty
is uniquely challenging, and uniquely needs
to be addressed by world
leaders around the world.
If you care environment, you care about poverty,
you care about any
issue out there in the world, investing in
girls, in you, is the most
thing that we can do. And today there were
about a hundred important
world leaders who got together in a room and
made you a priority told
you, told each other what they were going
to do in front of each other
to improve your lives.
We're going to post the action plan, it's
a ten point action plan, and
we are going to post that on Nikefoundation.org
and UNFoundation.org
and the coalitionforadolescentgirls.org
And that's a group of all of us who are going
to work together to
hopefully make your lives better.
So I hope this is good news for you.
Thank you so much for putting the video together
and we hope you girls
have your chance to transform the world, your
family, your community
and your country because you're the most powerful
people in the world
it's just the world doesn't know it yet.